Il pollo all'arancia è una ricetta per quattro persone
piacere peggio di quando mamma quando il
nonno silenzio è questa per fare il
pollo all'arancia petto di pollo
all'arancia
vi prego fammi andare via petto di pollo
all'arancia petto di pollo la ciao
ragazzi
bentornati a una nuova puntata di cucina
buttata oggi prepareremo il pollo
all'arancia qui dobbiamo tenerle per
forza certo
ok va bene fortunato che non si è
inventato guarda il considerando che
utilizzano dei coltelli se le fortunate
anche voi
scherzi a parte siamo tornati alle
vacanze più forti più chiatti che mai
avrò preso qualcosa tipo sette chili non
voglio salire sulla bilancia non è il
vostro computer che per sbaglio allarga
le immagini sappiate che sono così vi
prometto che quest'anno sarà l'anno
dell'alta cucina ci siamo chiesti che
cosa fare e alla fine diciamo le
macchine hanno scelto al nostro posto
perché non abbiamo personalità e siamo
delle persone
ok google mi mette in contatto con
giallo zafferano
ehi ciao penso che tu abbia voglia di
cucinare qualcosa di speciale che sa
cosa cosa vorresti cucinare il pollo
all'arancia petto di pollo all'arancia è
una ricetta per 4 persone di difficoltà
bassa serviranno 15 minuti per la
preparazione e 30 minuti per la cottura
ora posso darti più informazioni sulla
ricetta leggerti la lista ingredienti
oppure possiamo prepararla insieme cosa
vuoi fare
allora aspetto siamo 1 1 io e 5 enrico
quindi dobbiamo retto per le dosi danni
più informazioni sulla ricetta piede
alla ricerca di un secondo piatto
semplice e sfizioso e profumato sì
allora trovate il petto di pollo
all'arancia una ricetta
posso dirti gli ingredienti o possiamo
prepararla insieme cosa preferisci fare
demi gli ingredienti allora se ho capito
bene abbiamo otto di pollo all'arancia è
una ricetta per 4 persone
lo so ho trovati dal petto di pollo
intero 500 grammi succo d'arancia
sanguinello 130 gr di farina 00 40 g
burro 20 grammi grand marnier 40 gr di
olio extravergine d'oliva 25 gradi
palestino quanto basta per tenere quanto
basta posso dirti già attivo gruppo di
ingredienti darti più informazioni sulla
ricetta possiamo prepararla insieme che
cos'è grand marnier te è un visual
ecco cosa ho trovato crete sud est e per
preparare il petto di pollo all'arancia
così usate dai pomodori quando vuoi
procedere di ok google avanti ragazzi io
i pomodorini e con il contorno dei
pomodorini appassiti ma è il timo e jean
marc coma ha detto il tubo dividete a
metà la ranzani ottenete nel succo che
racchiude noi ci abbiamo come il
grembiule cerchiamo come dire che sto
facendo e il caldo non si divora tutto
mi sento rumori
vuoi interrompere la preparazione della
ricetta petto di pollo all'arancia
no mi dispiace di non poterti aiutare
torna presto
dividete a metà la rancia e ottenete nel
succo
se volete potete anche filtrarlo così da
eliminare suono di residui di polpa
tenete da parte
tu stai cercando un grembiule sta
impazzendo
ma gianmarco andiamo avanti ok e le
manette sono necessarie davvero sotto
sequestro
va benissimo quindi
ripeti in ultimo passaggio
non farla parlare la pazza la cosa
divertente è che non ho arance sanguigne
queste non sono minimamente arance
sanguigna prendete poi il petto di pollo
intero di proprietà e pulite da
eventuali residui di grasso e
cartilagini dividiamo loro a metà
ragazzi io io rischio di ferirmi che
periti non togliamo il grasso ma ti dico
a metano la padrona
se vuole rilevare male se non fatelo a
casa non fatelo a casa possa avere un
momento di brecht solo una ragazza è
troppo pericoloso dal suolo il taglio
del pollo sentire gli faccio per i più
piccoli tipo bocconcino xi peraltro alla
padrona è perfetto allora finissimo è
ora diretta verso uno già mi di mano e
molti colpo l'interesse per eliminare la
farina in eccesso non abbia fatto
bocconcino ce ne frega niente vorrei
dire che dice google
mettete a scaldare a fuoco dolce olio
burro non la fina il fondo sarà ben
caldo sistemate il pollo e lasciate
dorare per bene entrambi i lati fino per
un paio di minuti ciascuno lo taglia
alla fine è buono così fidatevi è una
bella infarinatura generale poi quando
si fa l'esame di maturità
un'infarinatura generale padella olio
burro
se facciamo rosolare un pochino polio
stiamo facendo una ricetta da veramente
colesterolo a 1.020 g non posso essere
di più se questa quella confezione da 40
grammi veramente 40 anni 125 grammi
erano
e vabbè ho messo un po di burro dai
ragazzi e il terrore che ci fosse
l'esplosione si aspetta apriamo la cappa
enrico nessuno può sentire l'odore di
burro tramite youtube e tu devi parlare
di odore di brewer ho mai silenzio i
prodotti di burro l'hotel si è un po di
burro
lo sento anch'io compensiamo
fate moltissimo
dobbiamo fare m tiri grand marnier
aspetta ce lo metto subito
ok però forse esagerato
occhio al fuoco aggiungete il succo
d'arancio giusto ragazzi quando vuoi
procedere di ok google avanti cioè sto
cucinando con le manette
cioè non ha senso tu piuttosto in che
modo così le manette
ma per arrestare visto un poliziotto non
c'è fino allora va riempito non c'è al
grembiule non c'è niente non c'è nemmeno
il pollo
dai miliziani domani sera
adesso proseguiamo senza coperchio
giusto lo saliamo subito non ha manco da
aspettare questo e per intero e vennero
queste sono bacche di ginepro come per
tanti che la funzione perché la storia
ma che questa eleggere visto in
lontananza no sembrava ho messo un bel
po di pepe correggiamo con del sale e
sale
guardate che bello che al lavoro cioè
per 4 persone questo
non mi sembra proprio ragazze del
momento di assaggiare venite e buono
come ho capito perché aveva così voglio
che lo facessi dovevano usare più spesso
le manette non ti dà qualcosa in più se
dovessi usare più spesso in silenzio
se più simpatico rientra nelle proprie
ricette su cile grazie al supporto più
veloce voi a studi finito di già era
buono ma lo è ma le scrivo comunque se
anche voi farete questa ricetta tagga
temi su instagram che sempre divertente
nel dire le storie delle quali alcune
persone si azzardano effettivamente ha
seguiti miei passi già questo video
mettetevi un bel pollice su per il noi
cerchiamo la prossima domenica ho sempre
alle 12 con a una puntata di cucina
nuttata ciao
si no
ti suggerisco sono pochi